what's our subject quickly
uh too slow
the reason
for the return
in the presence of god
and what pleases god will bless us are
you following me when god is pleased
people are blessed
when god is angry
let's please him today
favor number two while i'm speaking pray
for me and say lord put your words in
that man's mouth
jeremiah chapter 1 verse 9 then the lord
put forth his hand and touched my mouth
and the lord said unto me behold i have
put my words in thy mouth notice this
god's words are pure words are you
following me
as silver tried in the furnace of the
earth purified seven times god takes
that pure word
and puts it in a mouth made of dirt
so we have the divine
i that's divine have put my words that's
divine in thy mouth that's human
and i thank god for that honor
somewhere i read in elohis writings
angels sometimes ask god to let them
preach
and god says no
let them do it
because the angels want to talk about
jesus
and god no
let them do it so when i stand in a
pulpit i am aware that angels covet my
privilege
are you with me they covet you know the
bible says covet a good gift angels
right now are saying i would like to be
with that man is
and if that's the case i want to give
god my best can you say amen and so you
pray for me and say lord
put your words in that man's mouth
remember exodus chapter 4 verse 12 where
god said to moses now therefore go
i will be with thy mouth and teach thee
what thou shalt say what a promise i
will be with thyma i want the holy ghost
to sit right in here
i just want to be a loud speaker with
legs
god's voice coming out
all right favorite number three
think
don't tell me you're 86 you can't think
no no the only person who can't think is
a dead person
at any age god requires you to think
i'll tell you something the more you
think
the younger your brain becomes
scientists have discovered when you
expose your brain to a new experience it
generates new cells
[Music]
a 30-minute walk
generates new cells in the brain
you literally
re-shape your brain
and the bible says
the fear of the lord
is the beginning of knowledge
the bible is the most important book for
mental development
and so i ask you think as you listen
isaiah 1 18 come now let us reason
together set the lord let us pray
our father in heaven
thank you for prolonging our lives to
this afternoon hour
you have kept us alive not to give us
more time to sin
but to give us more time to turn back
to give us more time to recommit the
life to you to give us more time to
decide to love righteousness and hate
iniquity to give us more time to forgive
that person who hurt us to give us more
time to apologize to that person whom we
hurt
thank you for extending our lives dear
god
wherever did you forgive us please
forgive
now their god
grant us your spirit
without your spirit we will guide
ourselves into truth into error but
jesus said the spirit will guide us into
truth that's what we want and as we see
the truth they god let us make decisions
to follow it
bless everyone under the sound of my
voice they are your children and you
love them
bless them give them a consciousness of
your presence with them in this building
and on the internet
and as for me father
have mercy upon me
and tell me what to say
how to say it
and when to say it for i am weak you be
my strength stand with me in this pulpit
i pray
in jesus name amen
what's our subject quickly
ah too slow
the reason for the return
well no let's learn something about god
first something about god let's go to
titus chapter one
titus one we'll read from verse one all
young men should read titus and first
and second
timothy by the way thinking of young man
i like dr drake very much he looks like
a responsible young man and i like to
see that we live in a world where young
people are supposed to be frivolous
and just play games that run around no
no young people can be serious
if those expectations are placed upon
them
i heard one and a half amends but what
i'm saying is true young people can be
serious if adults will place serious
expectations upon them and support them
titus 1
reading from verse 1
i read from the king james version of
the bible if you have it read with me
what does this say paul
a servant and
apostle of jesus christ according to the
faith of god's elect and the
acknowledging of the truth which is
after godliness now read verse 2 in hope
of eternal life which god that cannot
lie promised before the world began the
bible says god
cannot
lie if that's clear say amen
he cannot
it's one thing to say he does not lie
it's another thing altogether to say he
cannot lie do you understand that always
keep this in mind when you read the
promises of god
when god has promised bring you all the
tithe into the storehouse
that there may be meat in my house and
prove me now herewith said the lord of
hosts if i will not open you the windows
of heaven and pour you out a blessing
that they shall not be room enough to
receive it he cannot lie
but his promises have conditions
he said bring the tithe
he said more than bring the tithe he
said
bring all the tithe.
if you do that
i will bless you beyond your expectation
there are some people walking around
burdened with a sense of guilt
guilt
the bible says if we confess our sins
come on say it with me he is faithful
and just
to forgive us our sins and to cleanse us
from all the righteousness god cannot
lie was preaching a certain place this
man came to me he said preacher can i
talk to you yes
i killed a man 25 years ago can god
forgive me
without going into jesus said have you
confessed your sin he said yes i said
god has forgiven you
now you may have to talk to the
authorities
are you with me
did jesus forgive the man on the cross
yes or no
did he take him off the cross no
he left him on the cross why because he
had offended the society
forgiveness doesn't mean you don't pay
consequences
forgiveness removes the condemnation
that sets you out of hell but jesus
forgave that man and left him on the
cross
now he knew he was saved he would have a
place being on the cross wasn't all that
bad
knowing that you're safe with christ
makes every other trial bearable are you
following me
all right god doesn't lie
let's go to numbers 23.
what book did i say
what number in the bible is that book
number four
and numbers is a proper name for it in
that book we find the numbering
of the children of israel exodus is a
good name for that book because it means
coming out
what's the key word in leviticus starts
with an h
then an o
then an l
then an i
holy
i'm glad you stopped me when you did all
right numbers 23 reading from verse 19.
do you have that
not yet all right numbers 23 reading
from verse 19.
let me pray again father
speak through me
speak through me in jesus name amen
god is not a man
that he should lie
neither the son of man that he should
repent
hath he said
and shall he not do it or hath he spoken
and shall he not make it good god is not
a man that he should lie what does that
text tell you about men or people
they lie yes they lie
god
does not lie
take that one step higher
god
cannot lie now having laid that
foundation
let's go to genesis 12.
god's
character
is a foundation of everything he says
god isn't shaky
god is immovable
that's why the psalmist says i will lift
up mine eyes into the hills from whence
cometh the hills seem to be eternal they
don't move
uh genesis 12 reading from verse one
do you have that one of the most
important passages in all the bible now
the lord had said unto abram
get thee out of thy country
and from thy kindred and from thy
father's house onto a land that i will
show thee
and i will make of thee a great nation
and i will bless thee and make thy name
great and thou shalt be a blessing
and i will bless them that bless thee
and curse him that curseth thee and in
thee shall all
families of the earth be blessed
let's read verses two and three again
and i will make of thee
a great nation
and i will bless thee and make thy name
great now i will make of thee a great
nation in order for that to happen
abraham must have what
children
go to genesis 11.
i don't know if god has a sense of humor
or not but i think of that when i read
this verse
read verse
30. you read it for me
come on
but cereal
was baron
she had no child
what is the bible telling us about serie
before she was sarah what's the bible
telling us about her
she could not have children
now we find that out first
are you with me
then we find out in chapter 12
that god said i will make you a great
nation
with god
nothing
shall be impossible
the barren womb is not a problem for god
uh you didn't hear me
the red sea
was not a problem god doesn't have
problems the only problem god has is us
the philistines were not a problem god
destroyed them
the egyptians were not a problem god
destroyed them the canaanites not a
problem god destroyed them the assyrians
came against jerusalem god sent one
angel he killed a hundred and
eighty-five thousand assyrian soldiers
god's only problem is us because he made
a promise to abraham and he has to keep
his word and so he kept saving the
israelites
but serie i
was barren
she had no child
with this in our minds now we read verse
2 of genesis 12 and i will make of thee
a great nation
and we found out about god
what
come on
he doesn't lie
so if he told abraham
you'll be a father of a great nation
and he also told us
sarah i couldn't have children where
should our focus be
on what god said
that's not the way we function
we keep our eyes on the problem
not on god's promises
go to romans 4 verse 19 and see how
someone who has matured in faith
thinks our subject the reason for the
return
is 4 30.
when does the sun set
7 30 who has to go to work before then
okay
all right roman chapter four
i thank you for smiling you're nice
people god bless you romans chapter 4
let's read verse 19
of romans chapter 4.
when you found it say amen some of you
are still looking
you're good looking but you're slow
romans chapter 4 reading from verse 19.
do you have that now
read it for me what does it say
and being not weak in faith listen
carefully now he considered not
his own body come on
now dead when he was about a hundred
years old neither yet the deadness of
pharaoh's womb
next verse says what
he staggered not
as a promise
through unbelief
next verse
but was strong in faith giving glory to
god next verse now and being
fully persuaded
that what he had
he was able also to perform stop let's
go back to 19.
now look at 19 microscopic
and being not weak in faith
what does that mean
now
yes
if you're not weak what are you you sir
think when you read the bible
and being not weak which means he was
strong in faith what does the next
statement say he considered not
what does that mean
notice he did not consider his body
what was the problem with his body it
was now dead reproductively
are you following me
here's a man who cannot father children
the bible says that's not where his mind
was
neither yet the deadness of sarah's womb
here's a woman with an infertile womb
she couldn't have children he cannot
father children his mind was not on his
inability or hers and ability his mind
was on god said
ah you're not listening you're not
listening
you're staring at me but you're not
now he could have put his mind on his
loins which were dead
which has done him no good
because staring at the dead person
doesn't bring it to life
staring at god in faith will produce
life from the dead are you following me
and so his eyes were on the word of god
which is another way of saying his eyes
were on god
because god said i will make you a greek
nation and the bible says he did not
consider his body he was strong in faith
in verse 21 he believed that what god
noticed how persuaded was he in verse 21
how persuaded was he fully persuaded
stop are you fully persuaded that if you
honor the sabbath god will take care of
you don't answer me
because they just ask you to work on
sabbath on the job
you know what the devil told god when he
went up to heaven and job chapter two
skin for skin all that a man hath will
he give for his life
listen to me that is true
if you threaten my livelihood i will
leave god
if you threaten my degree by telling me
don't take exams on sabbath i will leave
god
if you threaten my love life by telling
me don't marry outside the church i will
leave god
and very often god brings these
situations into our lives to test our
faith and to show us our faith is
nothing more than hay
and straw
abraham's eyes
were on thus saith the lord
because he had come to the place where
he knew
if god said it
he has to do it
listen to this expression carefully it
sounds harsh
god owes you
nothing
let me say differently
human beings cannot obligate god
now
let me give you a longer version god
owes us nothing
but he wants to give us
he owes you nothing
that's why there's grace
if he owed you something that wouldn't
be grace are you following me
no you're not listening
i mean just pulp it all by myself
god owes us absolutely
but he wants to give us absolutely
everything somebody say amen for god
that's grace
i don't have to do this but i want to do
it
the fact that you're a vegetarian all
your life doesn't mean god owes you
health
you kept away from sexual immorality god
doesn't owe you a husband
god owes us nothing
but he wants to give us
through jesus christ
now
so god made a promise to abraham you'll
be a mighty nation
let's stay in 12 let's go to verse 7.
of genesis our subject the reason for
the return
what does verse 7 say
and the lord appeared to abraham and
said unto him unto thy seed come on
will i give this slain it's genesis 12 7
where are you
oh you're in romans oh yes my fault
entirely
my fault please forgive the preacher
he's weak i did say i'm weak
are you back in genesis 12 7 now
thanks for getting this so quickly read
verse 7 for me
and the lord
appeared to abram and said
unto thy seed will i give this lamb
stop that's fine the ability and
alternate lord who appeared unto him all
right what did god promise abraham tell
me quickly i will give this land come on
to your seed
go to genesis 13.
very next
chapter
in this chapter abraham unlocked
separate sometimes to make peace you
have to separate
are you listening to me
sometimes for the sake of peace
you may have to separate a while
abraham a lot separated verse 14 of
genesis 13 what does the bible say
and the lord said unto abram after that
lot was separated from him lift up now
then eyes and look from the place
without come on now northward come on
southward come on eastward and westward
keep reading for all the land which thou
seest will i
come on
enter thy seed for how long forever now
think
when you travel to mobile alabama in
what direction are you headed if you're
coming from new york
south
if you drive to fairbanks alaska from
florida in what direction are you headed
north
if you drive to san francisco from new
york in what direction are you headed
west
if you drive to new york from l.a in
what direction are you headed west
east are there any other directions on
the campus no unless you say north east
south east
but it's all north south come on east
and west those are the four corners of
the campus now listen to god again
lift up now thine eyes and look from the
place with our art
northward
and southward
and eastward
and westward
for all the land which thou seest
to the will i give it
and to thy seed
forever
look
east or north whatever that is
if you look in that direction
and you look as far as you can look what
would you see
now you look as far as you can what
what do you see through the trees
if there are no trees what do you see
come on what is it
no
if there's no trees nothing to block
your view when you look what would you
see at the farthest extent
the sky
because the sky looks like a curve are
you following me you see the sky
so you would see beyond saint petersburg
are you with me
if you look south the same thing
north the same thing
rest the same thing
think with me now
when god told abraham to look what was
he telling abraham to look at
the whole world
i'll give it to you
now lord chose
sodom
and all the pastures next to sodom there
was water and grass listen to me
because
there are many opportunities doesn't
make it safe
left a hilly country for abraham
god told him
when he said look northward southward
eastward westward it includes all the
land that lot shows
ah you're not hearing me
i will give you in other words i will
make up and go beyond what was taken
from you as a christian if people cheat
you take it to god
don't sue the church
take it to god
he will make up
beyond your expectation don't sue one
another
all the land which thou seest
to thee will i give it and did i see it
forever that's what he told abraham
let's go to genesis chapter 27.
our subject what is it
the reason
for the return
17 minutes to five and the sun sets at 7
30.
we have time
what book did i say
genesis chapter 27 reading from verse
one do you have that
read with me what does the bible say
not 27 26
26 26.
all right what does that say
and there was a famine in the land
beside the first famine that was in the
days of abraham and isaac went on to
take gear to abimelech unto girard who
was the king of
bim like was the king the philistine he
went under bim like king of the
philistines ontagira all right
and the lord appeared unto him and said
go not down where
because that's where isaac was headed
but he had to pass the philistine
territory that because that's where
abraham went when there was a famine in
his time are you following me
because there was always food in
in egypt when i was a boy and i studied
geography at that time canada was called
the bread basket of the world
egypt was the bread basket of that then
known world and so isaac was making a
beeline for egypt but he had to pass
through gera the lord appeared to him
first two and said go not down into
egypt
dwell in the land which i will tell via
verse 3 sojourn in this land
and i will be with thee i will bless
thee read the next few verses next few
lines
for unto thee and unto thy seed come on
will i give all these countries
pause
no that's fine that's fine
god is telling isaac exactly what he
told abraham
i'll give the land to you
and to your seed
he told isaac i'll give the lamb to you
and your seed go to chapter 28
of genesis our subject the reason for
the return
we read from verse 12.
you have that and he dreamed
and behold a ladder set up on the earth
and the top of it reached the heaven and
behold the angels of god ascending and
descending on it now
read verse 13 with me are you ready king
james family are you ready
and behold the lord stood what above it
and said i am the lord god of abraham
thy father the god of isaac
finish the verse now the land whereon
thou lie liest come on to thee will i
give it finish the verse enter thy seed
now pause
what did god tell abraham
come on don't be slow what do you tell
him
i'll give you the land come on
till you see
what do you understand by seed
your children and your children all
right what did god tell isaac
i'll give you the land come on and to
your seed what did god tell jacob
i'll give you the land and to your seed
how is god referred to in the old
testament very frequently i am the god
of abraham the god of isaac the god of
jacob that's it
now i know he's the god of moses but the
bible doesn't say the god of moses aaron
and whomever he's the god of abraham
isaac and jacob he's the god of abraham
isaac and jacob he's the god of always
these three great patriots to whom the
promises were given and repeated
now
let's go to hebrews 11.
what's our subject
the reason for the return
do you have hebrews 11
we'll read from verse 8 beautiful
chapter hebrews
give me one word that describes hebrews
one word is famous for what faith
what is matthew 24 famous for
signs of the nes what is first
corinthians 13 famous for
ah god bless you you passed with an a
because you're adventists all right
where are we now hebrews chapter 11
reading from verse 8 let me pray father
continue to be with me let me seek your
glory not mine in jesus name i plead
amen
by faith read with me abraham when he
was called to do what
go out into a land which he should after
in receive for inheritance obeyed and he
went out not knowing whether he went
sometimes god puts you in that position
he tells you go
you have no clue where you're going
he just tells you go
when you take the first step i'll show
you the second
but i will show you step by step
not mile by mile
many of us want god to lead us six
months by six months
god leads us one day at the time are you
listening to me and he went out not
knowing whether he went
he's sojung in the land of promise as in
a strange country how is the land
described
read microscopically how is the land
the land of promise
why
he promised it to abraham come on to
isaac and to jacob so it's called the
land of promise now listen
this soldier he surgeoned in the land of
promise howe
it's right in the verse no look at the
verse
as industry yes
as a stranger
now
that's an estranged what does that tell
you
well that's true that's true that's true
that's true
but how was it described
no no no look at verse 9 concentrate
concentrate
how is the land described in verse 9
the land of promise what does that mean
he promised it to
to
do
does god lie no now
the bible says abraham lived in the land
of promise as if he was where
don't look at me look at the verse
as though he was where
in a strange country what does that mean
he hadn't gotten it yet
when he was living in canaan
he had just a promise
not the fulfillment
did i lose you
i'm too tired to go looking for you can
you come back
it was the land of promise
but he lived like a stranger because it
was not yet his
with exactly jacob the earth with him of
the same promise we have the three men
again
verse 10 come on read it for me
for he looked for a city which have
foundations whose builder and maker is
god now
let's read
verse 11.
um well skip verse 11 this is fair uh
sarah having isaac let's go to 13. read
13 for me
these all died in faith stop who is
these
abraham isaac and jacob they're
mentioned in verse nine
and if sarah is mentioned whom will we
have to assume rebecca and rachel
are you with me
because if he's the god of abraham isaac
and jacob he's also the god of sarah
rebecca and rachel
now
verse 13 says these all died
in faith
died in faith
what does that mean
[Music]
well they hadn't received it but
they died believing
that god will do what
keep his word
now faith is total trust in god's word
are you following me
they died
believing
now here's someone leaving this world
death seemed so final
they died
believing
with his last breath abraham believed
god will keep his word
but the bible says these all died in
faith read the next few words
not having received the promise but
having what seen them afar off and were
persuaded them and embraced them they
died
in faith
all right keep this in mind
go back to genesis 13.
what's our subject
the reason for the return
genesis 13 abraham and lots of separated
let's read verse 14
down to 15.
read for me what does that say
the lord said unto abram after that lot
was separated from him lift up thine
eyes now from the place and look from
the place with our
northward and southward and eastward and
westward stop now
we believe that abraham looked with his
physical eyes we believe that but
how are we to look
spiritually all right how are we to look
faith how are we to walk by sight
how i think so even though god told
abraham
look physically
what did abraham understand by faith
that god was promising him what
north south east and west are the four
corners of the what
the earth
what then did abraham understand
god had promised him come on the whole
world
now the bible says that
go to romans chapter four
romans chapter four
god has much more for you than you
expect
abraham might have thought kenan and
galilee god had in mind the world
you have in mind that young man who has
a car god has in mind a young man who
has christ in his heart are you
following me
no you're not all right romans chapter 4
do you have verse 13
you have verse 13
i keep saying read with me then i read
with you you read by yourself read verse
13 the first verse first line
stop
paul is telling us
that when god told abraham he would
inherit north south east and west god
actually meant what
the world
[Music]
now
let me ask you this question
did abraham actually receive that land
no
did abraham inherit the world no abraham
never heard of japan
abraham never heard of
argentina
he never heard of
north korea he never heard those
countries are not part of the bible
world are you following me
he had no clue there was something
called
the americas where we live
just his world
he didn't get it
these all died
in faith now
what's the only way to please god
faith
now if you died in faith how did you die
pleasing god
always speak with confidence even when
you're wrong are you following me now
listen again if you die in faith how
have you died
pleasing god why without faith it is
impossible to please god abraham isaac
jacob rebecca sarah rebecca rachel
they're all that high in faith they
please god
and when god please please with you he
rewards you
we found that god cannot lie
god still has to give that land to
abraham
it's the whole world
what has to happen
now look at me is there a picture in a
museum what has to happen
where is abraham
where is isaac
where is uh what's the other guy jacob
where are they
what does god have to do
he has to resurrect them
don't look so shocked
in other words listen to this beautiful
expression not because i said it is the
bible
not even death
can keep god
from fulfilling his word somebody say
amen
and even though abraham has been dead 4
000 years god must come back
raise up abraham isaac jacob give them
the land which he promised because if he
doesn't he has
lied and god cannot lie
ah you're not hearing me
i am saying that the promises of god
have the power to conquer death
that's why we must live
by every word
there's another reason why god has to
come back should i get into it it's five
times yes i'll get to it let's pray
father in heaven as we continue
help me to be gentle with your people
please because they're your people
but also help me to challenge them
in jesus name i pray
amen
go to genesis 3.
genesis 3.
my friends online wherever you are god
bless you thanks for hanging in with us
genesis 3 you have that
we will read a very familiar verse this
is god addressing the serpent
verse 15 read it with me you should read
it without looking really but say come
on
and i will put enmity between thee and
the woman between thy seed and her seed
it shall bruise thy head and thou shall
bruise his heel now listen again it
shall bruise
thy head
that is the seat of the woman bruising
the head of the serpent
if you want to kill a serpent you don't
grab the tail you hit the head are you
following me all right that's the fatal
blow remember revelation 12 13 verse 2
and i saw one of his heads as it were
wounded to death and the deadly wound
was healed the death blow to the head
okay
listen again
i will put enmity between thee and the
woman
between thy seed and her seed it
shall bruise
thy head the first mention of the gospel
now when did that take place
when was the devil's head bruised
at calvary
at a cross
no one will argue that but listen to me
carefully
is the bruising finished
no
why do you say no go to romans 16.
go to romans 16.
the job is not yet finished
part of the job is done but the entire
assignment has not yet been completed
romans 16
i want all of us to read it at the same
time
you have roman 16
all right
let's go to verse 20.
you have it now
my king james people read for me what
does it say
and the god of peace
shall bruise satan
under your
shortly stop
what is shortly
soon
which means it has not yet happened
where is that verse quoting from
genesis 3 15
which means that even though the major
bruising occurred on calvary there's
another stage to be done
are you with me
was satan bruised at calvary yes or no
is satan dead
no
does god have to come back and finish
him off yes
revelation 12
20 verse 10
and the dragon was cast into the
the
in the lake of fire where the beasts the
false prophet are
jesus christ has to come back
the second time
and the third
did you know there's a third coming too
when
after a thousand years
we need to talk more about that you know
the sunday churches have no clue
there's a third coming
when christ came the first time nobody
knew
you know why
the church didn't tell anyone
we can't let that happen when he comes a
second time
third time will be too late it was
actually a second time too late also now
christ has to come back
the second time to continue the bruising
this time he will isolate satan on this
earth
he will have no
one to tempt
a thousand years to reflect on all the
trouble he has caused in heaven and in
earth
then after a thousand years christ comes
back with us
say amen for us
not for for us he's coming with us which
means let's all plan to be there can you
say amen this is serious business
he's coming back with us
this time he will finally
wipe out satan
it won't be fun because it was christ
who created satan
not satan lucifer who became sin
it is christ who created everyone who
will be in the flames of hell
jesus christ must come back
reason number one he made a promise to
abraham
you must keep that word reason number
two he made a promise about bruising the
serpent's head it was christ who spoke
those words he must come back and finish
the job
the reason
for the return
the word of god
must be fulfilled
i told you earlier
god owes you nothing
he's not obligated to us he is not
you know what god is obligated to
his word
if god says it
he must do it
if it's unconditional he needs no
conditions if it is conditional we
fulfill the condition god does his part
if it is unconditional
he has to do it
if we fulfill conditions he has to do it
god is obligated to his word
not to us
but when we
live
by the word
are you following
when we take the word by faith
into us
when god fulfills it
he fulfills it where
in us
god is obligated to his word
and so he said
i will give you this land
he must resurrect abraham
isaac and jacob but he also said your
seed
he told abraham you and your seed isaac
union seed uh jacob union seed now we
know from galatians chapter 3 verse 9 if
he be christ
then are ye
abraham seed and heirs according to the
promise so god puts us right in the same
circle with abraham isaac jacob sarah
rebecca rachel and the saint petersburg
church
and the friends that came from other
churches
including michigan
ah what a tremendous encouragement
when
go to daniel 3 and then i'll
be merciful to you let you go
daniel 3
what is that chapter known for
the fiery furnace yes thank you my good
brother
listen what to what nebuchadnezzar said
you have daniel 3
i want just the men to read the men who
have the king james version now men
don't look bad in front of the ladies
come on read the word of god
you're supposed to be the leaders of
your homes to church society so set that
example amen are you ready
and the women answered for the men okay
okay
uh what kind of men do we have all right
daniel chapter three reading verse 28
are you there
men read with me nebuchadnezzar
spoken said
blessed be the god god of shadrach
meshach and abednego who have
sent his angel and delivered his
servants which trusted in him keep
reading
and have changed the king's word
stop
think with me
is god a king yes or no yes
who was the most powerful king back then
nebuchadnezzar come on concentrate
here is god the most powerful king on
earth here is god
the king of the universe here is
nebuchadnezzar the king of babylon
that means there is no comparison
maybe cadasta wanted to burn those three
boys
the bible says
the king of the universe changed his
word
your neighbor
trying to get you to lose your house
you're trusting god
god will change your neighbor's word
your boss is trying to get you fired
because you don't smoke you go to god in
faith and repentance god will change
that person's word god has the power to
change the word on earth the word on
earth cannot change the word of god
that's why you can't change the sabbath
he changed the king's word
now
the devil tried to change god's word
so working through the roman empire
under sanhedrin they put a guard at the
tomb of jesus to do what
to keep him from come on from coming out
they're trying to
change god's word jesus had said after
three days i'm coming up
the devil said ah
i'm gonna change that word so he put a
guard
a big stone
a seal then a guard of experienced
romans who all had the congressional
medal of honor they had fought in
battles
but when the first day of the week came
and the angel came down son of man or
son of god thy father
calleth jesus came out the bible says
those soldiers fell down as if they were
dead
because you cannot
change the word of god and the word of
god said you will inherit this land you
and your seed
and you and i are the seed
and the day will come when we will run
this earth the bible says this shall
reign with him you and i and christ will
run this earth but extend that rulership
we with christ shall run administer the
universe the reason for the return he
made a promise to abraham the reason for
the return he must finish off the devil
he has to come back
but the devil has us busy
with securing this life
so we forget
there's a life to come
but listen to whom god is coming listen
carefully let me pray father continue to
be with us as we explore your word help
me to remember i'm here for your glory
not mine in jesus name i pray amen
second timothy chapter four reading from
verse seven we'll read to eight read
very very carefully second timothy
chapter four seven and eight
our subject the reason for the return i
could have said the reasons for the
return
do you have ii timothy chapter four
readings verse seven and eight
very familiar passage particularly verse
seven read with me i have
fought a god fight i have
finished my course i have kept the faith
now carefully henceforth there's lit up
for me a crown of righteousness which
the lord the righteous judge shall give
me
at that day keep reading now are not
to me only but unto all them also that
love his appearing
[Music]
they think about it
they live for it they love his appearing
you know when your boyfriend says he's
coming over that's all that's on your
mind
you can't wait he said nine is
it's five o'clock you're looking
you love his appearing
your little children waiting for
christmas because they love the gifts
the bible says he's coming to give a
crown to those who love his appearing
and when someone is in love you can see
it
they're sick
it's called love sickness they're sick
but with a smile on their faces sick
now let's go to hebrews chapter 9. read
verse 28 with me
read 27-28 of hebrews let me hear the
ladies read hebrews 9 27-28 are you
there my lovely sisters you're not there
yet all right
let me see if you follow the men's
example in reading which was not very
good okay ladies come on do better than
the men do you have hebrews 9
27-28 read with me ladies what does it
say
after this the judgment uh-huh so christ
was once offered to bear the sins of
now real carefully now and until
unto them that what
unto them that look for him shall he
appear the second time without sin unto
salvation unto those who do what
they're looking for him what does paul
say to those that love his appearance we
look for what we love
god isn't coming to take people who are
too busy on this earth they never think
there's a second coming that's not the
person god is coming for
he's coming to them but not for them
he's coming to put them away
but he's coming to gather his sheep
and to those that love his appearing and
to those that look for him
he appear the second time
without sin
unto salvation
the reasons
for the return
he promised
abraham
and god does not
he must
resurrect abraham
in order to keep his word in other words
the resurrection will just be an
expression of the reliability of god's
word
if god says it
not even death can prevent god from
keeping his word
death can keep me a loss of job can keep
me from keeping my word to buy my child
a toy but there is no circumstance
that can keep god from fulfilling his
word somebody's amen for god
god is not a man
that he shall lie
neither the son of man
that he should repent hath he said
and shall he not do it
hath he spoken
and shall he not make it good is not
this the first lesson of the bible
and god
said
let there be light come on
and there's light
you apply that to anything and god said
let there be a resurrection
and there will be resurrection
it's the same word
god said to adam in the death outers
thereof thou shalt surely die read
genesis 5 and he died and he died and he
died and he died and he died
who said i will put enmity
jesus christ
who told abraham i will make your great
nation
jesus christ
who inspired
moses to write god is not a man the
spirit of jesus christ
it is christ
go to jude
verse 14 jude
the book of jude has one chapter so you
just call the first
jude 14.
jude verse 14
judas just before revelation
jude was a half-brother of jesus
there's another half-brother of jesus
who wrote the book of the bible who was
he
ah james yes brother james
jude 14.
read with me what does it say
and enoch also the seventh from adam
prophesied of these saying behold the
lord cometh with ten thousand of his
saints to execute judgment upon all stop
and enoch also
the seventh
from adam
let's see what that means
adam
seth
enoch
enos kainen mahalil jared enoch
when enoch was alive adam was still
alive
adam and enoch lived together many many
years are you listening to me
when enoch was alive as a man
adam was still alive
now go back to jude
verse 14
behold and enoch the seventh from adam
prophesied of this
the lord cometh with ten thousand of his
sins to execute judgment upon all and
convince all that the ungodly among them
of all the ungodly deeds if they have
ungodly committed and of all the heart
speeches with ungodly sinners have
spoken against him all right
now look at 14 again microscopically and
tell me exactly what jude is talking
about
the second coming
why is he not talking about the first
coming
he came as a baby
but listen to john 3 16 17 say it with
me for god so loved the world that he
gave his only begotten son that
whosoever believeth in him should not
perish but have everlasting life now
listen to 17 for god sent not his son
into the world to condemn the world
but how was jesus coming in june 14.
to execute judgment but that couldn't be
the first coming
how else is he coming in jude 14 behold
the lord cometh with ten
thousands of his saints how did jesus
come the first time by himself
then jude is talking about birth both
the second
and the third coming why do i say that
the judgment is not fully executed at
the second coming
it is executed
at the third
but one has to precede the other
i brought this to your attention to make
this point
the doctrine of the second coming was
preached while adam was alive
did i puzzle you
let me ask you then how early was the
doctrine of the second coming preached
come on
how early
when who was alive
adam who preached it
he not through jesus or jesus through
enoch enoch was the first prophet of the
bible
and the only message we have of this
prophet is the second coming
yeah you're not following me i'm serious
sister
the first prophet of the bible
is enoch
the only information we have of the
message he preached was
the second coming of christ
and the third
that's how important that doctrine is
i don't know what problems you're
wrestling with in your life right now
help is on the way
both for today and forever listen to me
jesus christ is coming back
now some of you are preparing for
christmas it's only march well april
you're already preparing for christmas
you're preparing for what's in may 26
what holiday do we have in may
what memorial day yes may then we're
preparing for july 4 you know what that
is then we're preparing for labor day
and we're praying for all the other days
yes but how many of us are preparing for
the second coming of christ let me tell
you something
we ought to prepare today
because if you die tonight that's it
i don't mean to bring a dark cloud of
depression if we pass tonight that's it
we cannot be so wrapped up in surviving
in this world that we lose the world
what did jesus say
what is a man profited come on tell me
if he shall gain
and the war loses lose salvation jesus
is saying it makes no sense
let me tell you a little secret that's
public
do you know what they were doing in the
days of lot while they were destroyed
listen to what the bible says
likewise also as it was in the days of
lot
did it eat
they drank they bought they sold they
planted they built it now
is eating a crime
drinking
buying
selling
building
planting
no
what work did god give adam a planting
work
who created fruit trees for food
god who made the rift of life god god
invented eating to such a degree in the
new world we eat
god himself builds a city
eating drinking
marrying giving in marriage planting
building none of those is of itself a
sin but when they preoccupy our lives
to the degree that they move god to
number two
all you're doing is building a decent
life for admission to hell
this is very serious
christ says he shall come as a thief in
the night
the thief surprises the people in the
house
what's the house the church
many in the church
will be surprised
when christ comes
because we're just not
looking for that
makes no difference how much we talk and
how we argue we because your behavior
shows
what you're looking for
let me urge you as your brother in
christ
someone who's struggling
as you may be
recommit your life to god
it's the most intelligent decision you
can make
recommit your life to god
every event in the world must be first
seen
biblically
the world sees it politically
the world sees it from an economic
standpoint
the world sees it from a social
standpoint now we can see it from those
standpoints but those standpoints will
only make sense as we place them within
prophecy are you following me
are you're not
if we only see them politically
we'll have a migraine
if we see them spiritually
we will rejoice
because our redemption come on draw us
nigh
whether it's presidential elections
coronavirus
north korea is a nuclear threat whatever
it is
first what is the biblical
interpretation
which makes us different from the world
the world sees politics natural
disasters we see fulfillment
of prophecy
heralding and announcing the soon return
of christ
and so i call upon you again with great
respect but with a burden for your
salvation
recommit your life to christ
he's your only hope and mine
because what is about to come upon us
will be so bad
the bible describes it
as a time of trouble such as the world
has
never seen
and you don't prepare for it when it
hits
you prepare for it before it hits the
bible says he that is faithful in that
which is least
is faithful also in much
whatever little trials are in your life
be faithful to god now
because what's coming is massive
and god says
if you cling to me in this time of
trouble
i know you'll stay with me in that
how many will say father
i recommit my life to you
i hold on to you hold on to me can i see
your hair hold on to me stand up with me
the reasons for the return
heads bowed eyes closed
before i pray
are there any prayer requests
yes
say it again
healing all right somebody yes
your family
yes
salvation of your family
say it again
okay all right okay the youth
your granddaughter
yes
sister joanna
what's that
god put adam in a garden the first city
was built by the first murderer kane
okay
yes sister
holy boldness to warn others destruction
is coming yesterday
come to christ
all right
wisdom oh yes wisdom
yes my brother
say it
again healing for your father okay yes
to not be ashamed to witness for christ
the bible says if you don't confess me
before men
i will not confess you before my father
your sister
your husband
yes
your son
your son and grandson
family
a new spirit ezekiel 36 26 god has
promised it ask him for it psalm 51 10
creating me a clean heart oh god
your grandson and family okay brother
williams grandson and family okay
yes
your children okay
make your calling an election sure
and grandchildren all right
yourself
your family okay
oh thank you ah god bless you
i need it more than you think
the devil is talk the devil targets
preachers
you smite the shepherd you scatter the
sheep he doesn't have time to waste this
get the preacher and the people will
fall
thank you very much all right let us
kneel
if you can if you can't god understands
father in heaven
we bow in your presence
because we have nowhere else to go
we come to god
because your word tells us let us come
boldly to the throne of grace
now we don't claim to come boldly father
we come because we know we're not worthy
but we come
jesus said come on to me
only that labor and a heavy laden and
father there is no burden like sin
we come to confess it
remove from us the god
all that is unlike you
because when sin goes problems go
when sin goes sickness go
because sickness is the result of sin
whether the person's sin or somebody
else is sin or just living in a sinful
world if there had been no sin there
would have been no problems
and so the key is get rid of sin
forgive us god where we've sinned
against you whether in thought word or
deed or even by potential but we just
did not have the opportunity do a deep
cleansing work day god
clean from the foundation up
because that's where the problem is
change our nature father
let us experience a rebirth
as otherwise says reconversion must take
place in the churches
now god
look down upon us with mercy father
we have hurt you so many times
we've let you down so many times
and you have taken our insults and with
your stubborn and persistent love you
continue to chase us
because you will be miserable without us
in the kingdom
and so father we stop and we allow you
to catch us
today circle us in your arms encircle as
their god
let us feel your heart beat against ours
let us experience the safety of being
within the arms of god
through faith
father you heard all the requests you
know them by detail
please respond
individually father
deal with every person as if that's the
only request that has come to you father
if anything is your will it is the
salvation of souls because you've said
in your word second peter 3 verse 9 you
are not willing the rainey shall perish
and for those praying for the salvation
of family
act quickly their god
in first timothy chapter 2 verse 4 your
word says and you cannot lie you will
have all men to be saved and to come to
the knowledge of the truth
some are sick
touch them
in exodus 15 26 your word you said i am
the lord
that he lift thee
but you also said in psalm 103 verse 3
who forgiveth all thy iniquities who
healeth all thy diseases and so getting
rid of sin and the income of health go
together
father
somewhat boldness to witness for you we
all need that
suddenly the greater understanding of
your word they god
some are being harassed by one person or
another whatever your people are
wrestling with in the name of jesus
christ
help them god
be their helper
and remind them that when they surrender
to you their battles become yours
and you will fight for us
father
bless this church
bless the visiting church members
bless our pastor
you guide him that he may guide us
and a special blessing on the children
father
lord
whatever we need we have not asked for
you give it to us
because you know our needs before we ask
fill our hearts
with hatred for sin
and give us a love for righteousness
father let us love righteousness just
because it's right not because it has
rewards just because it's right
give us that mind
as we leave now father remind us the sun
has not set
and even when the sun sets and the holy
day passes the sun does not set on our
personal holiness
we are holy seven days a week
sunset or not
let us have that understanding as we
move into secular time we are to be holy
people in secular time
uh god
strengthen us
and save us when you come
as you did for long the angels took him
by the hand and literally pulled him out
of that city if necessary grab us by the
hand and pull us out of this world dear
god
let us live as spiritual beings
father despite all the headaches we give
you we love you
and thank you for loving us
as we travel let angels go with every
car every truck every bicycle every pair
of legs
let that angel stand by our bedside
watch over us as we sleep
and father let us say in the morning
i wait for the lord sustain me
we pray from our hearts in jesus name
let god's people say amen and amen
god bless
you as you travel
reflect on what you heard this morning
and what you heard this afternoon think
because it is in meditation that the
truth is anchored in the mind and god
willing we shall see you tomorrow at six
o'clock pastor six o'clock tomorrow
evening try to bring someone with you
god bless you we'll see you tomorrow
you